evening I'm Hamilton fish of the nation
Institute Co publishers of thank you
good evening how's that I'm Hamilton
fish of the nation Institute Co
publishers of nation books I'd like to
welcome our live audience here in New
York and our viewers around the country
to tonight's conversation first a few
important items if they haven't already
been addressed cell phones please turn
them off we're going to be doing
questions to our panelists cards will be
passed around please fill them out pass
them to the end of your row we'll
collect them later on in the program and
following the program there will be a
book signing with both of our authors
books are for sale over in the corner
and I'll explain how the system will
work at that time the nation Institute
has a long tradition of sponsoring
public events dating back to a gathering
in the late 1960s in Los Angeles where
Reverend Martin Luther King first voiced
his opposition to the Vietnam War today
we are again immersed in war a different
kind of war perhaps but still one that
has left mothers all over America
grieving over the loss of their children
one such brave woman is with us tonight
she captured our hearts and opened our
minds with her vigil and Crawford this
summer welcome to New York Cindy Sheehan
long before Camp Casey for Abu Ghraib
before the Guantanamo detainees before
9/11 itself scott ritter was on the
ground as the chief weapons inspector
for the united nations special
commission in iraq a former major in the
US Marines ritter had spent several
months of the gulf war serving under
general Norman Schwarzkopf with Marine
Central Command headquarters in Saudi
Arabia in 1991 Ritter joined the United
Nations weapons inspection team or
unschool serving for the balance of the
decade he took part in 52 inspections
missions 14 of them as chief Scott's
latest book is Iraq confidential his new
title from nation books which charts the
disillusionment of a patriot who came to
realize that in its zeal for regime
change his own government sought to
undermine weapons control in the Middle
East and to conduct tonight's
conversation and perhaps to endure some
cross-examination himself we're
delighted to welcome legendary
investigative reporter Seymour Hersh
he is of course the author of the
stunning Series in the New Yorker
magazine on the use of torture by US
military and intelligence services in
the wake of 9/11 and I should add that
psy was the winner of this year's
Ridenhour award given by the nation
Institute and the Fertel foundation in
memory of Ron Ridenhour who played a
pivotal role in Psy's own groundbreaking
reporting on the malai massacres during
the Vietnam period the President of the
United States based his justification of
the invasion of Iraq on the existence of
weapons of mass destruction on Iraqi
soil and the involvement of Saddam
Hussein in the attacks of 9/11 senior
administration officials have repeatedly
denied the use of illegal and inhuman
treatment of detainees at various US
installations around the globe
mainstream American media has generally
parented these assertions and denials
because of the courageous work of the
two fearless individuals with us tonight
the world now knows the truth please
welcome Scott Ritter and Seymour Hersh
what I'm going to do since and make sure
if you can't hear me do yell as if I
have to tell you what I'm going to what
I'm going to do is just ask God a series
of questions and I've read his book a
couple of times and basically we're
going to try have some fun
consider Scott and I your little
orchestra playing on the deck of the
Titanic as it goes down because we're
all in great trouble here so Scott to
begin before we even talk about how we
got to where we are in terms of where we
are the critical question is the way I
look at it my own personal view is we
have two options in Iraq we can get our
all our troops out by midnight tonight a
and option B we can get them all out by
tomorrow night at midnight and so I
wonder I wonder where where you sit on
that what's your view well you know I
view that Iraq is a nation that's on
fire I mean it's just there's a horrific
problem that faces not only the people
of Iraq but the United States the entire
world about what's happened in that
country and the fuel that feeds that
fire is the presence of American and
British troops this is widely
acknowledged by the very generals that
are in charge of of the military action
in Iraq so the best way to put out the
fires to separate the fuel from the
flame so I'm a big proponent of bringing
the troops home as soon as possible
today is the best day we're going to
have in Iraq tomorrow is going to be
worse in the day after that's going to
be even worse but we also have to
recognize that you know that one of the
reasons why we didn't move to Baghdad in
1991 to take out Saddam was that there
was wide recognition and if you get rid
of Saddam and you don't have a good idea
of what's going to take his place
that Iraq will devolve in the chaos and
anarchy well we've done just that we got
rid of Saddam and we have no clue what
was going to take his place and so it's
simply pulling the troops out is only
half of the problem I think there has to
be another half of the equation which is
dealing with three critical issues that
have emerged since we invaded a the Shia
and I'm not talking about the mainstream
Shia of Iraq I'm talking about this
political elite that's pro-iranian that
is
conducted a coup d'etat so to speak
they're running the government today be
the Sunni we took a secular bulwark
against the expansion of radical
anti-american Islamic fundamentalism and
we've radicalized them themselves and if
we just pull out and leave the situation
as it is we've turned the Sunni
heartland the Sunni triangle into a
festering cesspool of anti-american
sentiment it's the new Afghanistan the
new breeding ground for al Qaeda and
then one that nobody talks about in the
media is the Kurds we we somehow have
given the Kurds this false sense that
they're going to have an independent
homeland and yet our NATO ally Turkey
has said this will never happen and if
we allow the Kurds to move forward
towards independence we're compelling
the Turks to radical military
intervention at a time when turkey has
just been invited to enter into a 15
year negotiation with the European Union
about becoming a member of the European
community if the Turks move against the
Kurds that negotiations over which means
that Turkey has been rejected by Europe
and will be heading towards the embrace
of radical anti-american Islam so it's
not just about getting the troops out we
have to recognize that there are three
huge issues ongoing in Iraq that affect
the national security United States and
we need a policy to address these but
keeping our troops in Iraq is not part
of that policy how do you get them out
how quickly what do you think about that
the quicker the better I mean I'd leave
it up to military professionals to
determine how you reduce perimeters
there are some areas of the country that
you can just literally up and run but we
have a significant force in place we
have significant infrastructure in place
and we have an active insurgency that
would take advantage of any weaknesses
but I guarantee you this if we went to
the insurgents and I do believe that
we're having some sort of interaction
with the insurgents today and said we're
getting out of here all attacks would
stop they'd they do everything they can
to make sure that the road out of Iraq
was as AED free as possible
a lot of people disagree with that a lot
of people this is an administration one
of the things that's always remarked
over me in terms of how the press
doesn't push certain issues and the
Congress and admittedly on any given day
it's it's in my view of the Congress is
that are the Senate and particularly
they're there you know you can't decide
whether they supine or prone but they're
down and so we've had a you know along
with the Democratic Party so we've
really had a serious problem but how a
very wise man said to me the other day
somebody that knows the Middle East well
knows that Shia well he says you don't
even understand your peril he said
speaking about our country here and this
administration he said the goal no
longer is to remove us out of Iraq the
goal now is to get us out of the Middle
East well I mean first of all I don't
think we want to get out of the Middle
East until we got some serious issues
that Hurricane Katrina has highlighted
our addiction to oil and until we solve
this addiction we are going to be
interacting with the Middle East and I
don't think it's a matter of no I'm what
I what I actually meant was that it's
the Shia want us out no I'm saying it
but somebody clapped about maybe that's
a good thing for us to get out of the
Middle East I don't think it's a good
thing for us to get out of the Middle
East I think we have a responsibility to
our own citizens and indeed to the to
the world to leverage the enormous good
that our country represents into doing
good in the Middle East that you know
American presence doesn't have to be
negative in its connotation today thanks
to the Bush administration when we say
an American presence in X country or Y
country it generally has a negative
connotation because the Bush
administration doesn't have the best
interest of the world or even the
American people in mind when they carry
out a certain course of action but I do
believe that we have to be concerned
about this
Shia concept and I would even go further
and call it an Iranian concept where the
Iranians are saying that we can take
advantage of the serious missteps that
the United States has made visa vie Iraq
to reassert Iran or Persia as the
dominant power in the Middle East and
unfortunately if we continue to stay the
course as the Republicans in the Bush
administration speak of and indeed many
Democrats including
Hillary Clinton and others who aspire to
national leadership stay the course stay
the course plays right into the Iranian
hands needless to say this isn't a
debate where it is too bad but let's go
back to the beginning one of the things
about the book that's amazing is that
it's not about the Bush administration
and if there any villains in this book
I'm talking about Scott's new book if
they're any villains
they include sandy Berger the national
security advisor and Madeleine Albright
and basically what this book does and
there's been so much talk I know we're
going to have to deal with it and
eventually with the New York Times and
all the problems there but one of the
things that's breathtaking about this
book in terms of as me and news as a I'm
always been a newspaper guy is the
amount of new stories the new
information
Scott's describing a in more detail and
with named sources basically or two or
three run of the American government
under cutting the inspection process and
essentially I think it's fair to say and
the question I would ask is in your view
all during those years 91 to 98
particularly the last three years when
everything got so intense was the United
States interested in disarming Iran Iraq
rather well the factor matter is the
United States was never interested in
disarming Iraq
the whole Security Council resolution
was geared that created the UN weapons
inspectors and called upon Iraq to
disarm was focused on the one thing and
one thing only and that is a vehicle for
the maintenance of economic sanctions
that were imposed in August 1990 linked
to the liberation of Kuwait we liberated
Kuwait I participated in that conflict
and one would think therefore the
sanctions should be should be lifted
the United States needed to find a
vehicle to continue to contain Saddam
because the CIA said all we have to do
is wait six months and Saddam is going
to collapse on his own volition that
vehicle is sanctions they needed a
justification the justification was
disarmament but understand that a
chapter 7 resolution of the United
Nations Security Council calling for the
disarm of Iraq and saying in paragraph
14 that if Iraq complies sanctions will
be lifted within months of this
resolution being passed in the United
States was a drafter and voted in favor
of this resolution within months the
President George Herbert Walker Bush and
his Secretary of State James Baker are
saying publicly not privately publicly
that even if Iraq complies with its
obligation to disarm economic sanctions
will be maintained until which time
Saddam Hussein is removed from power
that is proof positive that disarmament
was only useful insofar as it contained
through the maintenance of sanctions and
facilitated regime change it was never
about disarm it was never about getting
rid of weapons of mass destruction
it started with George Herbert Walker
Bush and it was a policy continued
through eight years of the Clinton
presidency and and then brought us to
this current disastrous course of action
under the current Bush administration
one of the things that's overwhelming to
me was and as a journalist was the
notion that everybody believed before
March of o.3 that Saddam had weapons
this is just an urban myth the fact that
the matter is that in my personal
experience and this I man in the Scott
went about 98 99 and in talking to
people who worked and on the uncommon
also in the International Atomic Energy
Agency which did a lot of very
first-rate reporting and you know the
some of the people who wrote some of the
reports former intelligence agents from
Britain among others
they were pretty much clear by 97 that
there was very little likelihood that
Saddam had weapons and there were many
people in our State Department or the
Department of Energy in the CIA who
didn't believe there were weapons and I
think history is going to judge the what
I can almost call almost mass hysteria
we had about Saddam on weapons and one
of the questions that keeps that keep
and that keeps on coming up now is white
and Saddam Telus did he tell us well of
course he told look let's let's be
honest the Iraqis were obligated in 1991
to submit a full declaration listing the
totality of their their holdings of WMD
and they didn't do this they lied they
failed to declare a nuclear weapons
program they failed to declare
biological weapons program and they
under declared their chemical and
ballistic missile capabilities Saddam
Hussein intended to retain a strategic
deterrent capability not only to take
care of Iran but also to focus on Israel
what he didn't count on was the tenacity
of the inspectors and very rapidly by
the by June 1991 we had to come we had
compelled him and do acknowledging that
he had a nuclear weapons program and we
pushed him so hard that by the summer of
1991 in the same way that a drug dealer
who has police knocking at his door
flushes drugs down a toilet to get rid
of his stash so they can tell the cops I
don't have any drugs
the Iraqis not wanting to admit that
they lied flushed their stash down the
toilet they blew up all their weapons
and buried it in the desert and then
tried to maintain the fiction that they
had told the truth and by the 1992 they
were compelled again because of the
tenacity of the inspectors to come clean
people say why didn't Saddam Hussein
admit being disarmed in 1992 they
submitted a declaration that said
everything's been destroyed we have
nothing left in 1995 they turned over
the totality of their of their document
cache again not willingly it took years
of inspections to pressure them but the
bottom line is by 1995 there were no
more weapons in Iraq there were more no
more documents in Iraq there was no more
production capability in Iraq because we
were monitoring the totality of Iraq's
industrial infrastructure with the most
technologically advanced the most
intrusive arms control regime in the
history of arms control and we knew that
while we couldn't account for everything
that the Iraqis said they had destroyed
we could only count for ninety to
ninety-five percent we knew that a we
had no evidence of a retained capability
and B no evidence that Iraq was
reconstituting and furthermore the sea
I a knew this the British intelligence
knew this Israeli intelligence knew this
German intelligence the whole world knew
this they weren't going to say that Iraq
was disarmed because nobody could say
that but they definitely knew that the
Iraqi capability regarding WMD had been
reduced to as near to zero as you could
bring it and that Iraq represented a
threat to no one when it came to weapons
of mass destruction but you were very
worried all the way through the end
about what you call the concealment
mechanism why don't you tell the
audience about that the concealment
mechanism I mean you know here's the
thing Hussein Kemal the son-in-law of
Saddam Hussein defects in August of 1995
and he's debriefed by the CIA by British
intelligence and by UN weapons
inspectors and his debriefing on all
three occasions is consistent on two
things one all weapons had been
destroyed Hussein Kemal repeated this
over and over and over again there's
nothing left in Iraqi said but then he
talked about what happened in 1991 and
he said yeah Saddam's bodyguards the
special Republican Guard the special
security organization they were hiding
weapons back then and they're still
hiding documents and components today
and you need to go after these guys and
so that's what we did I mean you know we
had been lied to by the Iraqis in 1991
they had a mechanism and placed them to
hide things from us the Iraqis have come
clean about the fact that they hid
things and where they are but they never
talked about how they hid it and now
we're being told that it's ongoing today
so now we have to investigate what
occurred in 1991 who did it and then we
have to make sure that it's been
disbanded and they're not doing it today
unfortunately that means going after
Saddam Hussein's security this is like
the Iranians coming in until in the
United States if we want to investigate
the Secret Service and how they protect
the president there's no way Americans
would let that happen and there was no
way the Iraqis we're going to bend over
and let us come in and inspect Saddam
Hussein's security forces the other
element in in in all of this of course
is that as Scott writes about there were
things going on inside his old
organization that he didn't know about
operations being run by the CIA and in
effect I think
it's not an overstatement to say in your
book in your belief anyway and by the
way I I can say that as a journalist
I've independently talked to people and
verified much of this all of it one of
the things that was going on is we kept
we as we provoked Saddam and demanded to
get into as your group did the UN
demanded to get to the palaces their
concern was of course that the real
meaning the real effort was to
assassinate them and lo and behold well
that's exactly what happened I mean look
the American policy was regime change at
first they wanted to be passive we're
just going to contain Saddam through
economic sanctions and he's going to
collapse on his own volition in six
months that failed we're going to put
pressure on the Iraqis and we're going
to get some Sunni general to apply the
75-cent solution the cost of a
nine-millimeter bullet put in the back
of Saddam's head and the Sunni general
takeover if you want proof positive
about the corrupt nature of our regime
change policy understand this it wasn't
about changing the regime it wasn't
about getting rid of the bath as party
or transforming Iraq into a modern
democracy back in the early 1990s in
nineteen it was about getting rid of one
man Saddam Hussein and he was replaced
by a Sunni general who governed Iraq in
the exact same fashion that was okay and
that shows the utter hypocrisy of
everything we did but the CIA was having
very having a difficult time getting
near Saddam because he has his
outstanding and I don't mean that in
terms of a bunch of good guys but a very
effective security apparatus by 1995
Saddam's continued survival become a
political liability to Bill Clinton and
he was coming up for re-election in 96
and he turned to the CIA and said get
rid of Saddam by the summer of 1996 I
need that man gone
the CIA worked with British intelligence
they brought in somebody named eaat
allow it might be a name familiar to
people he was for a period of time the
interim prime minister of Iraq after the
American occupation before he was
interim prime minister however he was a
paid agent of British intelligence in
the CIA and he worked with them to
orchestrate this coup d'etat that
required them to recruit people on the
inside of Iraq to be ready to take out
Saddam but she needed a trigger and
trigger was a UN weapons inspection that
I helped organize we thought we were
going after the concealment mechanism
but it turned out that the CIA was
setting us up so that we would go to
facilities that house Saddam's security
we would be blocked it was anticipated
they would block us and then when we
withdrew there would be a military
strike that would decapitate the
security of Saddam the one place that we
wanted to go to the third battalion we
weren't allowed to the CIA don't worry
about that we know those guys they're
not bad and they were supposed to rise
up and take Saddam out well the Iraqi
intelligence service is very effective
at infiltrating this coup they wrapped
it up and you know nothing happened in
terms of getting rid of Saddam except
one thing the Iraqis were fully aware of
the role played by the CIA in
infiltrating nun's calm and using nuns
comfort of devices and in the ultimate
tragedy of this is that from that point
on every time a UN weapons inspector
went into Iraq somebody with a blue hat
they weren't viewed by the Iraqis as
somebody was trying to disarm Iraq they
were viewed by the Iraqis as somebody
trying to kill their president and they
were right when did you learn about this
we always knew about regime change I
mean when I first came in we knew about
regime change in terms of the
infiltration you know some people say
it's my fault because I'm the guy that
brought in the character I call mo Dobbs
and the special activities staff the
covert operators of the CIA we used them
in 1992 we use them in 1993 because it's
tough to do inspections in Iraq you know
they're not necessarily the friendliest
people in the world when you're trying
to go to a site that they don't want you
to get in and you can't have a bunch of
thin necked
geeky scientists trying to do this job
you need you need guys are you talking
about New Yorkers no but you need guys
with thick necks and thicker arms and
the CIA had plenty of these guys who
could do logistics they could do
planning they could do communications in
austere environments so we use these
guys and we use them in in June that the
problem came afterwards when we do start
doing follow-up inspections first of all
the Iraqis would come to me and they
would say mr. Ritter what are you doing
you know you're supposed to be an
inspector and yet you're doing all this
bad stuff we know about the CIA's coup
attempt and I'm going to look good
we know what happened in June what
happened in June and suddenly we start
inspecting sites and they see documents
that start sending off signals in my
head about oh my gosh the unit the CIA
didn't want us to go to was the unit
that was liquidated by Saddam Hussein in
the aftermath of the failed coup because
that was the unit they was trying to
take out Saddam and selling though the
you know the light goes off and you're
sitting there going you know we've had
the the wool pulled over eyes we've been
used up we were used by the United
States though and they're the most
powerful nation on the Security Council
that we as inspectors work for it
so how do you turn to your boss and say
hey you've used us we won't tolerate
that well you can't do that what you
have to do is continue to plod forward
and just redouble your efforts to
maintain the integrity of a process that
tragically had been terminally corrupted
by that point so let's see we've got the
Clinton administration looking really
good here what I always say I when I do
my when I do speeches I always start by
saying the bad news is let's see now
there's eleven hundred ninety days left
of the Bush presidency and the good news
is tomorrow morning there'll be one less
and so the question is so if Clinton
wasn't so good where are we now
well I mean I'll start off and I want to
highlight that point that the Clinton
wasn't so good you know there's a lot of
talk today in the Democratic controlled
Judiciary Committee about going after of
the Bush administration for for crimes
for for lying to Congress and etc and
you know I'm all in favor of that bring
on the indictments but don't stop with
the Bush administration if you want to
have a truly bipartisan indictment take
it down and you indict Madeleine
Albright you indict sandy Berger you
indict every person on the Clinton
administration that committed the exact
same crime that the Bush administration
has committed to today lying during the
course of your official duty that's a
felony that's a high crime and
misdemeanor that's language in the
Constitution that triggers certain
events like impeachment so let's not
just simply turn this into a bush
bashing event this is about a failure
not only the Bush administration but of
the United States of America and we have
to look in the mirror
recognize that what all the Bush
administration did is take advantage of
a systemic failure on the part of the
United States as a whole a failure that
not only involves the executive but it
involves the legislative branch Congress
whether they're prone or supreme
whatever you want to say Congress has
abrogated its responsibilities under the
Constitution and they've abrogated it
for years
then there's the media and yes we can
turn this into a media bashing event but
you know what the media only feeds the
American people the poison they're
willing to swallow and we the people of
the United States of America seemed to
one-hour news in no more than three
minutes with sound bites of 30 seconds
or less and it can't be too complicated
and so what we did is allowed ourselves
throughout the decade of the 1990s to be
pre-programmed into accepting at face
value without question anything that was
negative about Saddam Hussein's regime
and this made selling the war Iraq on
the basis of a lie the easiest task ever
faced by the Bush administration there's
always the argument that one virtue of
what we did no matter how bad it is we
got rid of a very bad dictator what do
you you know I have my answer to that
what's your answer to that one well be
interested here what your answer isn't
but that you know look that that invokes
the the notion of the ends justify the
means I mean that's that's basically
what we're saying here is that who cares
about the lie who cares about the WB you
know we got rid of a bad guy the ends
justify the means and I have to be frank
if there's anybody here who calls
themselves a citizen the United States
of America and you endorse the notion of
the ends justify the means submit your
passport for Destruction get the hell
out of my country because this is a
country that is founded on the rule of
law as set forth by the Constitution of
the United States a constitution that
the men and women who serve us swore an
oath of allegiance to the Constitution
that our government every government
official swears an oath of allegiance to
and it's about due process
democracy is ugly sometimes it doesn't
work as smoothly as we wanted to do but
if you're sitting here and saying that
when it comes to Saddam that the ends
justify the mean where do you draw the
line where do you draw the line and
say tell me that it's only going to stop
here it's about the rule of law it's
about the Constitution and if we wanted
to get rid of Saddam Hussein then we
should have had a debate discussion and
dialogue about the real reasons and not
make up some artificial ways of
structure this is this is not Plato's
Republic I mean it's uh and and there
are a lot of realities well there are a
lot of give-and-take on all these issues
for example I always joke and I think I
I mean it I always the one thing Bill
Clinton did that strikes me as
remarkable as he was the first American
president since World War two to
actually bomb white people in in Kosovo
so there is some good he isn't as bad
it's just the the real issue for me in
this issue in in the Bush administration
and the ease with which you know the
ease with which they move from the
attack of 9/11 into an invasion of
Afghanistan and let me assure you the
whole story of that I'm doing work on it
but the whole story that isn't is simple
the idea that you're just going to go
after all the Taliban there wasn't that
wasn't that them wasn't that clean a
decision there was a lot of
give-and-take that we didn't see
publicly but the ease in which we moved
into the war in Iraq and does strike me
as getting at the fabric of democracy
because we literally were taken over I
think I think it's not an exaggeration
to say by eight or nine neo-cons
a cult if you will and we were taken
over and and there was for all of your
talk about and I know you I know you
mean it I know there are many people in
who served in the military you share
your view and are just as far bent about
it as you are but yet the military has
been totally docile we haven't had one
senior officer go public as we can we
can trash the Congress all we want and
we'd still be ahead of the game
the
ah cracy the federal bureaucracy we saw
awful lot of acquiescence the press has
been this is I think history will judge
this is one of the low points of the the
response the bush will be a low point
for the American press corps so where
are we what do we go from there how
powerful is democracy how close I wait
to the edge what happens now
well the the deal about democracy
especially American democracy is that
it's supposed to be a participation
event you know we've got this wonderful
thing called the Constitution a I'd like
Americans to start reading the
Constitution and understanding what that
document means that way maybe people
wouldn't sit there and say well Scott
Ritter it's pie-in-the-sky Plato's
Republic no it's not it's what we stand
for
it's what the values and ideals of our
nation are they're enshrined in that
document and there's no other document
in their world like it but the fact that
most Americans haven't you know my wife
comes from the former Soviet Union she
and she had to actually study the
Constitution and take a test on the
Constitution before she became a citizen
and so she knows the Constitution better
than the vast majority of natural-born
Americans and and so Americans need to
start to come to grips of who they are
because unless you know the Constitution
understand what representative democracy
means and that's not just about voting
people in it's about holding people
accountable for what they do in your
name then you're not a citizen and
that's what we lack is listen let me ask
you this as somebody who comes knows the
military pretty well what about the
failure of the military to speak out I
mean what do you think I know there's no
answer but what do you think I have a
hard time blaming the military for this
you know there's a gentleman he's a
colonel and active duty today HR
McMasters that wrote a great book about
the Vietnam War called dereliction of
duty and it's about the failure of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff to to stand up and
do the right thing about Vietnam and the
same dereliction of duty is taking place
today by the Joint Chiefs of Staff yes I
agree
there's comes a time when you're a
senior officer in the US military when
you see the civilian leadership behaving
in the manner that they are it's not
about picking up the phone and calling
the gern
list and I know that would do you great
harm if they stopped doing that but it's
about taking the stars off your collar
and throwing them on the table and say I
will not be a part of this charade and
nobody's been willing to do that but
let's get back to reality
where's McMaster now you know well
McMasters a brigade commander in in Iraq
I think you know in combat operations in
telephone he was the great commander in
Tal Afar I can tell you just from this
is that that's the operation took place
a few months ago in northern Iraq it the
worst part of it took place during
Katrina there were men in the military
were very happy about the lack of
American attention workers been
dwindling anyway at one point I'm told
we had more than a hundred raids
air raids on on that village I've had
officers come back and used the word
genocide and talked about turning in
actually talking about turning in their
colonel what is a bird winger what is it
turning in his is the full bird Colonel
zazz eagle wings as Eagles okay turning
in his Eagles on talking to me about
what they consider to be genocide and
and at one point the the Turkish Red
Crescent the Red Cross in Turkey came
and came across and offered to provide
some support for the 200,000 people of
tal tal afar that had been bombed given
in obscurity because of Katrina and they
were told no by us and so what do you
what is the system that makes a guy like
McMaster who could write such a
brilliant book about which the generals
still talk they still get together the
generals still talk about their lack of
morality or a morality or whatever it is
they worry about it in their own private
meetings I've talked to people who've
gone they meet together three or four
times a year so what is it about this
war this president where are we with
this stuff what's going to happen
who's going to break out and tell us the
war there in case anybody has any
illusions if if you were to read the
Arab press about what's going on every
day when we have stories talking about
guys in the New York Times the other day
maybe
yesterday pilots flying supersonic jets
saying they saw 25 to 40 insurgents go
into a building so they destroyed the
building killing that many insurgents
insurgents is the new word for body cart
count and it just goes down so smoothly
I just see it happen the pressed is
automatically glams on to the notion
that everybody with a we say is in this
urgent is insurgent is and yet if you
look at Hyatt and the other press and
you get a sense every day those papers
are filled of little children dying
being maimed and the amount of hatred
that's being generated against us the
amount of resentment the number of
jihadists were creating the the the war
in Iraq is is not an external war it's
an indigenous war and it's getting worse
so why not blame the military why not
say one of those guys should speak out
well I'm not saying that they shouldn't
speak out I mean you know it would be
wonderful and it's not a pressure on HR
McMasters but if he set the set the
example if he came back from Iraq and
said this is a war that's not only
unwanted but this is a war that's
morally unacceptable and I can no longer
participate in this conflict and he
resigned
who knows that might set the standard
for other men of Honor to step four but
it's a very difficult thing to ask a
soldier to do what the average American
citizen won't I mean why do we put the
burden on the soldier to speak out
instead of putting the burden on the
American public to become more empowered
to become enraged about what's happening
to vote out of office we got an election
coming up in 2006 rather than waiting
for McMasters to resign
why don't we vote out of Congress
everybody who voted in favor of this war
well
and I know I don't live in reality but
that's still well so let's talk about
the press a minute we got to get to that
a little bit and uh you're going to want
I think we're going to want questions
eventually right let me read you some
stuff that was said about you this is my
favorite one actually I'm not picking on
the New York Times but it just happens
to be my favorite one it was a long
piece that was done about Scott in the
fall of oh - what five months November
would have been five months before the
invasion and and the headline of the
piece is Scott Ritter it's a magazine
piece Scott Ritter's Iraq complex and it
says war definitely is Ritter's
prediction he told me this the other day
he sees no room for optimism he said he
was talking about the Security Council
at this time if you remember the Bush
administration and Blair the eternal
puppy dog I guess we're talking about
going back to the UN and he said it's
just a set up a smokescreen the Bush
administration has put his reputation on
the line this is Scott talking whether
or not weapons are found expect the
bombing to begin he says he talked about
Scott is quoted as saying the
presidential palaces in Iraq may have
underground bunkers but they're not
underground factories quote there's no
James Bond there's no dr. evil the
Iraqis are incompetent they can't do it
and my favorite line is the next one
well maybe they could so why couldn't
you get the press to take you seriously
one of the problems is that the press
wasn't looking to have a discussion
based on reality because that's too
nuanced that's too complicated that's
too gray the press wanted black and
white and it also the problem was you
know you have this former marine former
hard-nosed weapons inspector who was
bitching a lot about the Iraqi so long
I'm not on their capability right a man
singled out by Saddam Hussein is you
know the personification of evil
suddenly gone soft and and that was just
a combination that they
pres didn't know how to deal with zip
flop they said I was a flip-flopper uh
and and so rather than deal with the
complexity of a problem and believe me
there's no single answer to too many of
these of these questions the the WMD
issue in in the lead-up to the war was
one that I was not saying that Iraq had
no WMD I said that the inspectors had
never completed their job we needed to
let the inspectors go back in and finish
the job before we talked about going to
war that when the president says he
knows that there can be no doubt that
there's WMD in Iraq that implies
certainty of knowledge that has to be
based upon fact and that this
administration had failed to put any of
that fact on the table and all I was
asking is that the administration make
its case because short of that case we
can't talk about going to war we need to
let the inspectors do their job that's
too complicated for Barry Burak that
author and other people out there who
frankly speak and didn't know how to
deal with this this guy called Ritter
and the message he was trying to put out
there but in terms of Saddam do you
think maybe we we get we we need fixes
we need a Hitler fix seems to me that
we've gone from Hitler we go to Stalin
we go to Mao we go to Joe and I we go to
Khrushchev we go to at some points
Gaddafi certainly home a knee you you
run through the list we seem to always
be fixated on you know dr. evil I guess
to use the cliche so is that it that we
we can were so easily brainwashed into
thinking that Saddam was by nothing
nobody's suggesting that he's not you
know this is despicable etc let's make
that we're not there's no apology here
obviously for him but there are an awful
lot of very bad people out there
and
why what a horrible thing to say that
others may see us you know I think about
I'll tell what I think a lot about I
think about the bombing and here's what
I think about in this war bombing is an
integral part of this war and you will
find next year as this president tries
to extricate himself politically and
before the congressional elections you
will find he's going to trade American
soldiers for American bombs and since
this war began
there's been no air defenses of the
Iraqis the we have seen no statistics on
how many bombs get dropped sorties they
call it how many mommy flights how many
missions by one plane by each plane a
sortie we have no statistics we don't
have embedded reporters on the carriers
that are in the Gulf we don't have it up
and we don't have embedded reporters in
the air bases in Doha and other places
that that fly around the Clark missions
we just don't know where there are a
hundred missions a day at Aleph are how
many missions are being flown right now
is there an X is it exponentially
increase and our ignorance and
willingness to remain ignorant then
default the press to the inability to
ask questions why shouldn't a bomb that
falls in a house and kills a mother
father and six siblings leaving a 15
year old boy to determine he's going to
spend is less the rest of his life
getting revenge why isn't that as much
of a terror weapon an American bomb as
as an AED or error car bomber well the
answer is it is it is and it's an
amazing sort of inability to look at it
from that way but do you have any
optimism as we get them with our little
thing here no I wish I did I mean that
the sad fact is one of the reasons why I
was arguing against this war was not
just that it was based on a lie but it's
a reflection of the reality that was
recognized in 1991 that if you remove
Saddam and you don't have a clue what's
going to replace it on you're going to
get chaos and Anarchy and people
continue to say they want the elegant
solution in Iraq that's the
everybody's like well we can't withdraw
because we kind of solve all the
problems ladies and gentlemen there's
not going to be an elegant solution in
Iraq there's no magic wand that can be
waved to to solve this problem yeah well
look if we get out and we have a plan
you know it's still going to cost 30,000
Iraqi lives let's understand that
there's going to be blood shed in Iraq
they're going to kill each other and
we're not going to stop it if we
continue to stay the course however the
30,000 number may become sixty or ninety
thousand at the end of the day we've
created a nightmare scenario in Iraq and
the best we can do is mitigate failure
and that's what I'm talking unfortunate
that's a politically unacceptable answer
people say no we have to win we have to
persevere there has to be victory
there's not going to be victory what
about the chances of expanding the war
what about the chances of expanding the
war into Syria or even you know into
Iran well the the sad thing right now
not not that's just cross-border stuff
the sad thing right now is that we have
a bush administration that's populated
by people that don't understand war
they've never been in the military
they've never served in combat and they
don't know what it means to have a son
die I would have a friend I have a
brother die or have a comrade die and so
that's why you have a secretary of state
like Condoleezza Rice who has the gall
to stand before the American people and
say that war is the only guarantor of
peace and security and now she testified
before the US Congress today and she
said that not only is Iraq probably
going to be another 10-year investment
of time blood and national treasure for
the American public but that Syria and
Iran may very well be the next targets
of the Bush administration so this this
administration has learned nothing
what's what's worse is that Congress has
learned nothing there were no tough
questions to Condoleezza Rice and now we
have the American people what lessons
have we learned what actions are we
going to take where is the American
media and that's a good question I have
for you where is the American
area
well
somebody I know somebody are no higher
official who disagrees off the record of
course or privately said to me about
condi he said well when she became
Secretary of State we all heard that
she'd have the president's ear but we
didn't know that all she do is lick it
oh I don't know what to tell you about
the press you know I until this week I
would be I would be I was always because
I spent so many years at the New York
Times and The New York Times is for all
of its fault it's it's ours national
standard it's the paper by which
certainly during Watergate or when I was
writing for it from 70 to 79 I felt that
in going going on the writing about
Vietnam and writing about the coup in
Chile and writing about my my favorite
born-again liar mr. Kissinger you could
you could you could do you could really
write with great freedom and it's
sometimes I think in just going through
the carefully looking at the stuff over
the last few days I I think sometimes
that maybe tell me the solution the
short you know the New York Times
Corporation is a very big industry it's
got a lot of its internet a lot of cable
companies other media radio stations
maybe they should just spin it on to
somebody you know who knows how to run a
newspaper because I'm you know Murdoch
maybe there's a good suburban newspaper
chain in Westchester or northern New
Jersey or maybe a bunch of kids in the
Ailey Daily News could get their daddies
the COFF up enough money to buy and they
could want take it over but somebody's
got to do something because it's too
important an institution to be
floundering the way it is and we all
have a stake I ask somebody work that we
all have a stake in making this paper
and urging it to get better quick
because it is a paper that essentially
failed in the mission it had against
Bush it had a mission to tell the truth
and it did not
and and please listen you can't just
blame judy miller it's not that simple
no you know I'll tell you something
about that story which interest me know
n is that she had been doing what she's
been doing for six or seven years there
was no question about where she stood in
particular the last three years about
who she was dealing with and here comes
the Joe Wilson story she's an expert
allegedly in the times on WMD weapons of
mass destruction she was with the early
teams that went into the war she wrote
about it from the administration's point
of view but she certainly was an expert
here's Joe Wilson he writes an op-ed and
we know she knew about it in advance but
assuming even otherwise the editors may
not have known what she knew and he
writes this dramatic story about the
administration being caught out in a
definitive way by from somebody inside
here's somebody inside assemble and said
said something of importance and it's
not an anonymous source and she's not
assigned to do the story why to me
because they understood what she did who
she worked with so the paper was
empowering her in a way in other words
an honest journalist with the expert
you'd want it if you had a perception
that she would an honest straight
journalist you could do it and so um
that's not her failing that's an
institutional failing that it was
recognized that she only represented
that side of the house and that's not
the paper I knew and that's not the
paper we should stand for let's do some
questions okay I just did the first one
talk about the reporting at Judy Miller
I think that was coming can we talk
about the likelihood of a bush
administration attack and Iran what it
might involve and what the results might
be I do you want to do some of these you
want to read them I know you read them I
don't care well let me do this lest we
should answer that question okay
tackling Iran is not going to give up
the nuclear weapons it's a country Cyrus
the Great they're not going to give up
the weapons
oh they did they're not going to give up
their ambitions then let's put it that
way
Oh dah dah that's not that's does well
factoids the fact is they're there they
have an ambition they weren't very
straight about it they didn't they
misled the iaea this guy want a Nobel
Prize because he had an awful lot of
integrity Albury date and so their hands
aren't you know admittedly from their
point of view if you if they're
surrounded by people with bombs who
won't you know have bombs who aren't
their friends they have Israel which is
always in any discussion the elephant in
the room of any policy they have Israel
viewing Iran as the existential threat I
think it does the leadership there does
as an existential threat certainly more
than Iraq and what scares the hell out
of me is I know some of the things
they're doing we haven't stopped very
aggressive actions against them very
aggressive covert actions we've been
doing increasing it we've been making
threatening very threatening explicit
threats of the most horrific kind and
everybody everybody every wise man I
know says to me that we can't do it we
just can't do it because it's Iran is
too powerful
we don't have an armed forces if we did
do it there would be if you think Osama
bin Laden caused trouble here on 9/11
there are three million Iranians in
America you would see things happen here
that would be unbelievable sorry a
question for both of you to what extent
do you consider the maintenance of
perpetual war a priority for this
administration to fuel high military
spending continued military spending I
don't know about fueling continued
military spending I I've always likened
the neo cons as parasites who attach
themselves to hosts and they've attached
themselves to the Republican Party our
party that I'm a member of
and I know that elicits hissing and
booing in many corners of America today
but the it's incredible any here the the
the neocons are a minority element of
the far-right wing of the Republican
Party these are people who flourished in
the 1980s during the Reagan
administration when they had the evil
empire and they were and because you had
an evil empire because they had a focus
they could sit there and talk about
certain empowering devices such as you
know programs to build weaponry programs
that exploited the fear and the
ignorance of the American public when
the Soviet Union went away the neocons
were at a loss what do you do you need
something to replace it that's where
Paul Wolfowitz and others came up with
the idea of stepping into the vacuum and
talking about global domination and they
wrote a variety of papers that came out
first in 1992 then in 1997 as the vision
statement of the project for a new
American Century and today it's
manifested itself as the national
security strategy of the United States
which were promulgated in September 2002
one year to the date after the September
11th attacks and I think this is a
vehicle that does create the conditions
of perpetual war because with perpetual
war you have perpetual fear and when the
American people are perpetually ignorant
this fear can be exploited it's been in
sploit advection ministration and their
neoconservative parasites
you Scott you raise the three-part issue
Sunnis Kurds and Shias but you don't
paint the rest of the picture what is
the rest of the picture and can you
flesh out with Iran Turkey and Israel in
the region
well I raised the three issues that are
internal to Iraq which are the Shia the
Sunni and the Kurds what I didn't talk
about is the the solution
I said withdraw troops look that's first
and foremost the boys and girls got to
come home and they got to come home now
unfortunately they're not going to but
let's say we get them home how do we
deal with these three issues it's going
to require a multilateral approach with
the United States playing a role
not necessarily the leading role you
need the Turks to give the Kurds of Iraq
assurances that legitimate autonomy will
be respected and we can work with the
Turks on that because we have one hell
of a leverage called European Union
membership
you need the Syrians to work with the
Sunni to talk about walking away from
Wahhabism to get back to that secular
base and we have leverage with the
Syrians I thinks I could probably talk
about the role that the Syrians
intelligence has played and being the
true supporter of the American war on
terror Syria has provided my understand
is some of the best intelligence about
Al Qaeda Jordan will play an important
role Saudi Arabia will play an important
role Kuwait will play an important role
and you know what the Iranians will play
an important role because again we have
leverage we can leverage a recognition
of an Iranian nuclear energy program
under full IAEA safeguards we can
leverage a lifting of the economic
embargo that we've imposed on Iran to
get the Iranians to back off on Iraq
it's difficult it's not easy but you
know what it's called diplomacy and
that's a lost art form here in the
United States
so that also in order to do that this
president this administration would have
to talk to the Syrians and the Iranians
and so far they have not and officially
to these surgeons to Scott Israel has
the arsenal of nuclear bombs why is
Israel immune from inspections Israel's
immune there's real some uniform I mean
that the easy answer is they're immune
from inspections because there's no
mandate out there to inspect Israel now
the question is why is there no mandate
out there to inspect Israel because the
United States of America is a
veto-wielding member of the Security
Council we will never allow a resolution
to be chaired that threatens the Israeli
nuclear weapons program worse we will
never allow the Israeli nuclear weapons
program to be interjected into the
debate we just pretend it doesn't exist
we hold Iran accountable for the
non-proliferation treaty when in fact
Iran has not violated the
non-proliferation treaty Iran is
complying with the non-proliferation
treaty and yet we pretend that Israel's
doing nothing wrong now I'm a very
fervent supporter of the State of Israel
I believe Israel has a right to exist
and I believe that we should work with
Israel to develop the means of
peacefully coexisting with their
neighbors but you know it has to be
based on the same standard when we have
this double standard we say the Israelis
could do whatever they want including
working with a nuclear weapons program
and nobody else
else in the world killing that's a
that's a policy formulation for disaster
to two questioners come at this from
different angles one asks why is no one
talking about the civilian casualties
caused by military action in Iraq and
the other reports that she read the DoD
website the other day where apparently
they list five civilian deaths those
questions answer themselves I will say
something about Israel in this book
Scott describes in great detail how
competent he eventually turned away from
America and its intelligence services
and took much of the of some of the raw
intelligence that had to be analyzed
overhead-cam were working intercepts to
the Israelis because they could do it
better quicker and I ended up people
thinking you were what an Israeli agent
well I was accused of being his really
spy but you know the Israelis brought
more integrity to that process than the
United States and the CIA ever did when
I started in 1994 Iraq was the number
one threat to the State of Israel this
was put out in the official Israeli
National Intelligence Estimate when I
left in 1998 Iraq was number six and
falling and the reason is that the
Israelis had actually embraced the
process of disarmament that was
represented by the UN weapons inspectors
when you do intelligence cooperation
with a nation it's imperative especially
as a weapons inspector that you know
it's a give-and-take relationship it's
very difficult you have to give
information they give you a response and
it's a feedback loop so it's an
intelligent cycle and it requires close
cooperation if Israel used is what could
very well abused the information that we
were providing them to target Saddam
Hussein and remove Saddam Hussein and to
carry out a very aggressive policy
against Iraq but the Israelis recognized
if you remove Saddam you got a bigger
problem than simply keeping Saddam and
they treated the intelligence with an
integrity that was lacking in the United
States United States took everything we
gave them and instead of helping us
disarm Iraq they went out and targeted
Saddam Hussein this is a question for
you sigh do you think that a tripartite
as has been posited by Peter Galbraith
and others as Sunni Shia Kurd tripod
state in Iraq you consider it viable and
in particular the Kurdish state oh I
think it's it's absolutely the perfect
horrible trifecta you're going to get a
Shiite state in the South that's going
to work very closely under the hands of
the Iranians be much more aggressive a
hostile to Israel which is not a policy
that we want you're going to get I
always used to say you're going to get
Somalia in the center of the country the
Sunni land right now what we're doing in
the Sunni land
if anybody has any doubt we're simply
killing people the goal is to make the
Sunnis more frightened of us than the
insurgency that's how we're going to try
and get intelligence and that's what
we're doing Bam Bam Bam and in the north
a friend of mine teaches at one of the
war colleges and he has some Turkish
officers in the course and they said
nothing they were discussing the the
formation of a Kurt Curtis two
independent Kurdistan and finally my
friend asked one of the Colonel's sir
you know Colonel what do you think about
Kurdistan and he said sir he said there
is no Kurdistan I mean it's it's not
going to be pretty and I don't know I I
wish I could I wish we could have the
I'm not aware I disagree with you guys I
don't think we'll do anything to be able
to keep the Turks out of there I think
we could look we could be looking at a
serious war there and these guys just go
along dancing their game spinning it out
making threats as condi did today to
Congress not being challenged on it
publicly by anybody in the Congress is
that right there was very few not no
acrimony in geology now there's nobody
took her on they just sat there like
compliant little servants and listen to
condi dictate and that was the end of
the debate they licked their ear Wow but
what also gets me on the issue of
breaking Iraq up and do three separate
nations because this is an argument
that's put out there it's just basically
correcting the mistake of history that
Iraq is not a genuine nation stage it's
an artificial construct that emerged at
the end of the First World War
etc and what astounding hubris one must
have to think that the United States of
America
is empowered to go back and redraw the
lines on a map
anywhere in the world because we're
correcting a mistake of history the
mistake of history is being made by
embracing such an absurd notion that we
have the ability to come in and divide
up a group of people without really
consulting the people themselves I'd
like to address a couple of questions
that deal more directly with domestic
politics and activism tens of thousands
of Americans converged on Washington
last month against the war cindy sheehan
reignited the anti-war movement and now
someone is camping out by Blair's house
yet everyone still feels disempowered
what more can Americans do many members
of Congress voted for the war based on
misinformation should all of them be
voted out of office the short answer is
yes I think that your wiki look I'm
going to get in trouble with the
anti-war movement here but I'm just
going to tell you my personal opinion
you know these demonstrations that take
place you know 100,000 people get
together they hold hands they light
candles they sing Kumbaya then they go
home and there's no follow-through it's
a it's an exercise in self gratification
and there's no follow-up
they always flounder and that's one of
the problems they need to have a focus
it can't be anti this it's time we
engage in pro-democracy and that means
that we establish the basic conditions
of representing the American people and
one of these basic conditions is if you
voted yes we vote no you're out in 2006
and that has to become the mantra if
you're voted yes for war we vote no and
you're out and it's time that we start
growing a new generation of American
leaders why do we continue to allow
special interests in these various
parties whether it be a Republican Party
or Democratic Party to put such awful
choices up before the American people to
represent them in positions of extreme
importance the fact that George W Bush
and John Kerry were the two choices we
had in the last election is the most
harsh indictment
of the system we have in place today
that this this require this requires
some speculation but it's pertinent and
probably interesting given Hillary
Clinton's vote for the Iraq war and
subsequent posture on this question how
do you think she would shape Iraq policy
where she to make it to the presidency
Hillary's the classic chickenhawk she
doesn't know anything about the military
she doesn't know anything about national
service she's a woman that now because
she is so weak on national defense and
frankly that's a reflection of a
terminal illness within the Democratic
Party as a whole a weakness on national
security so she has to be more right
wing than the right wingers and she's
going to head us even to worst problems
in Iraq than the Bush administration I
don't know side if you disagree well I I
just am appalled that our our former
President Clinton says nothing it's just
I think it's shameful this is shameful
you know let me say something about a
month ago that about a month ago the
Democrats some of the leading theorists
including sandy and Madeleine Albright
had a meeting a secret meeting in
Washington secret meeting hasn't been
reported yet as far as I can tell in
which they have debated what to do
and they ended up concluding the general
conclusion was to the horror of some was
that well the Republicans are
floundering now is it's let's let's do
nothing let's say nothing and let him
bottom out and the notion that the
leadership would let more Americans and
Iraqis and others perhaps die and
Afghanistan's die because they might be
able to steal Kentucky or Georgia away
for the Republican Party you know if
they if they go quiet is really so
abhorrent and one just says I'll tell
you what I saw that was very interesting
in the last election
I saw the Democratic Party devalued in
many of them particularly in the Middle
West I saw the union's doing a great job
I saw acorn I saw a lot of public
interest groups a lot of moveon.org is
it whatever I saw a lot of groups that
are not necessarily from all different
classes work together in a very
effective way and I think that's what's
going to happen is I think people are
just going to do what Scott said I think
they're going to find better candidates
and and it's going to be I think the
party the Democratic Party is going to
be forced to be more coherent on this
issue well I don't know we always seem
to have somebody we've got we've got
we've got two years I can get you know I
when I was a kid reporter 1,800 years
ago I left the Associated Press I I
covered the war I was covering the
Pentagon and I learned in by the fall of
1967 I really did understand that we
were doomed that this was a horrible
event and so I quit and went to work for
gene McCarthy because he was the only
guy then that was willing
to stand up against Linda Johnson his
own party and say I'm against this war
and it'll happen again
and here's a really safe prediction to
somebody who wants to be a national
leader the next guy that goes public the
next senior politician democratic goes
public firmly and solidly against the
war is he's got a shoo-in this question
this question first I Hearst
how much direct influence does Vice
President Cheney have on defense
secretary Rumsfeld and the conduct of
the war
well I'm you've just got the guy I mean
that this is the this is the key guy
it's more than that I would say under
President I mean you know I there's no
question that Cheney has been the single
force and one of the great mysteries one
of the great mysteries I think that
historians are going to have to try and
struggle with his he he did not sign
some of those manifestos in 97 and 98
would be Wolfowitz and the others Doug
Feith he was always a realist he was
always a hardliner
he did not in he was somebody who
supported the decision in 91 not to go
to Baghdad when is when Bush's father
was under pressure to do so if you read
and hear some of the things he said
running for the vice presidency in 2000
and what he said he was not that way
what turned cheney after 9/11
into the raging and what what
oh yeah well you know it's a there's a
little we know nothing about this white
house you got it that's a given we know
nada they just operate in ways that we
can't see again in the category of
speculation had Gore won in 2000 with us
still have invaded Iraq or pursued in
some other way regime change in Iraq
Gore did win is the easy answer I uh art
and I know I just wrote one book and
that's the one people should be focused
on but I did write another book back in
1999 called in game and I in there I
discussed the issue of America's Iraq
policy and I said look the policy were
on is a policy of inevitable
confrontation there's no out there's no
vehicle for diplomacy it's about regime
change and so in Eveleigh what's going
to happen is as we push and push and
push we're going to hit a wall where we
either have to turn left and capitulate
and no American politician is going to
capitulate on the issue of Iraq or we're
going to turn right and we have to
confront decisively militarily and
unilaterally and this doesn't matter if
you're a Republican or you're a Democrat
Al Gore was married to the policy of
regime change Al Gore was married to a
policy of deceiving the American people
about the reality of Iraq and if Al Gore
had been elected in 2000 America would
have ended up fighting Iraq maybe not
along the lines that the Bush
administration has pursued but we would
have had to confront Iraq okay
he's breaking your heart let's go back
to the Middle East Scott it seems that
private security contractors are nothing
more than mercenaries who have no
accountability to the United States to
Iraq or to international law that you're
nuts and it seems that way look as a as
somebody who served in the military
there's no greater honor than to serve
your country in the Armed Forces United
States of America so it's a it's a
wonderful thing because you take an oath
up over defend the Constitution against
all enemies foreign and domestic
it means something it means a lot it's
actually a cause worthy of the sacrifice
of life I was was willing and I am
willing today to give my life in service
of my country because I believe in
something because I believe in the
Constitution I believe in an oath if
your value basis for service becomes
monetary you stop being somebody who's
serving because of Honor because of a
cause and you start becoming a mercenary
and there's no other way to describe it
private contractors have no role
whatsoever in the waging of conflict on
behalf of the United States of America
and
and let me just say that was that was
great Scott because you're right on it's
an incredible problem they're
outsourcing there's a wonderful word we
use rendition which is basically you
know disappearing we called it two
decades ago and Brazil and Argentina
just grabbing people its outsourced now
we outsource we pay a group of retired
CIA guys we have a company to go grab
somebody perhaps it's a little more
sophisticated than than going into the
jungle but in Tal Afar
the colonel the one colonel who told me
with great horror about what he saw
there was there for three three months
he said at various times the worst
killers were teams of Iraqis led by an
American retired American Special Forces
of CIA retired paramilitary guy who
would come back in ISM as a mercenary
Salvadorian style and going they would
go into these towns and villages where
they thought there was trouble and just
rip up people and if they were come it
was it's it's so prevalent and so
demeaning to us the extent to which this
administration has resorted to this kind
of thuggery and this kind of murder
incorporated business it's just shocking
it's something that Congress does not
want to look at it's something that the
press I've actually seen favorable
stories about some of these killing
teams which is amazing to me and I was
talking about one in a New York Times
Magazine just amazing could you
summarize the role saudi arabia is
playing in the region and particularly
in the iraq kimberly oh well i can tell
you one thing there isn't a major
construction company or large saudi
business mostly as you know the saudis
are sunni that isn't financing the
insurgency there's just no question and
it's not just saudi arabia all over the
sunni world in the middle east it's an
arm matter of honor to support the
insurgency the insurgency and i
the Sunni insurgency that's involved in
is life and death struggle with us is
being financed by people who see what
this certainly what we call insurgents
they see them as people defending
themselves from the occupation the
wrongful occupation of the United States
I don't know if that's what I'm told I
don't know what you think of what you
hear Scott about that issue I have to be
honest and say that I'm probably not
that equipped to answer the question
about Saudi Arabia and what they're
doing in Iraq other than to note that
the Saudi Arabian government has been
struggling with the issue of Islamic
fundamentalism the form of Wahhabism the
the sect of Sunni Islam that's been
embraced by Osama bin Laden and al Qaeda
in Iraq today in western Iraq and the
Sunni Heartland you see a resurgence of
Wahhabism and this is a great concern to
the to the Saudi government I think they
would prefer a return to a secularism
that's uh that's not there right now
we've denied the Sunnis of Iraq the
right to exist as a people we've taken
that away from them
we've disenfranchised them we even
allowed the Kurds and the Shia not as a
people but as individuals Jalal Talabani
the president of Iraq today
has occurred who waged war against
Saddam Hussein's government in the
nineteen in during the iran-iraq war
this is about revenge Jafar is the head
of Dawa a terrorist organization
sponsored by Iran that tried to
assassinate Saddam Hussein you look at
this trial today that's taking place in
Iraq it's not about law it's about
revenge
why did they pick the smallest crime
that Saddam Hussein committed because it
was a Dawa assassination attempt that
went a foul that Saddam Hussein attacked
Dawa and now dawa's and power in Iraq
today getting revenge
Saudi Arabia is very concerned about
what's going on and what's the vehicle
to deal with this diplomacy the United
States has ruled out diplomacy so it
doesn't surprise me in the least that
the Saudis would be funneling resources
uh two selected Sunni insurgents a
matter of Honor and just as a final sort
of I think it's important for Americans
understand that we we are fighting a war
against the people we started the war
against two and a half years ago in
other words we began a war against the
Sunni Baathists we did not win when
Sadat 1-bath that the Baghdad fell all
have happened is Saddam before the war
set up a guerrilla operation Smyth cell
operation insurgency pre-planned at all
and we're now in year three of a war
against the people we started and a
four-star general just the other day he
said to me well we're not winning it and
therefore we're losing it in a sense
we're not when we're in the middle of a
in the third year of a war against the
batha Sunni regime with or without
Saddam they're fighting us and they're
fighting us pretty hard and again that's
my interpretation I just wonder how you
see it well absolutely I mean look there
was no Missouri moment the Iraqi
government did not surrender
the Iraqi army did not lay down its arms
it was amazing you talk to some people
about the situation in Baghdad and
journalists saw this on April 6th
there's roadblocks at every street
corner manned by Special Republican
Guard Republican Guard Baathist militia
security forces intelligence forces all
dug in the whole town is armed to the
teeth ready to fight a block to block by
block defense of Baghdad on April 7th
they're all gone
why because Saddam Hussein said look I'm
not going to sacrifice Baghdad you guys
go disappear we have a plan let's
implement the plan you know
the Bush administration's criticized
rightly so for not having a plan for
post-war Iraq well guess who did have a
plan Saddam Hussein and his plans
trumping our lack of plan every single
day we're in Iraq for both of you
strangely underrepresented entity in
this conversation the United Nations is
there a role and can they be effective
that Nations is a
membership it's a club and it only works
if its members abide by the rules that
they all agree upon those rules are
embodied in the United Nations Charter
as an American I need to point out that
article 6 of our Constitution states
that when we enter into an agreement or
treaty that's in ratified by two-thirds
the United States Senate that is the law
of the land this is the Constitution we
have signed the United Nations Charter
and yet on a daily basis we violate that
charter not just in Iraq but around the
world the United Nations will never
succeed as an organization until the
United States of America decides to be a
full and responsible partner in
accordance with the rules that we expect
all other nations to abide by it's been
said during the course of this evenings
conversation that the u.s. presence does
not have to be negative could each of
you comment on what kind of presence
would be positive you know there is room
there's always room I'm going to I'm you
know this is the glass half full
business there is room Iran is not as
Scott suggests that they're not nearly
as intractable as you one might think
they're sitting there looking at a
nuclear reactor being built for peaceful
use by the Russians and they're saying
to themselves Chernobyl Chernobyl
Chernobyl they would love to get Western
help in that and that reactor because
the Russians always deal sort of
third-rate quality to their to their
that's one of their famous they don't
deal as straightforwardly as with their
allies as they should in terms of
supplies and that the best stuff and so
they're worried about it there's a lot
of room for negotiating with Iran if we
were if we were chose to I there's they
are trying to make contact I can tell
you the Syrians this I know an awful lot
about I've been reporting on something
there for months the Syrians are there
is no empirical evidence by the way and
I'm sure the German will come up with
none either necklace about who killed
harary that does that doesn't mean that
the the Syrians didn't do it it doesn't
mean that anybody into it we just don't
know and and the Syrians want to play
and so we could actually as bad as it is
nobody has got said earlier there's no
virtue in chaos in in in Iraq and yet
when you have a cult cults always have
um by definition they have a public and
a private meaning in the in the cult of
Wolfowitz fight cult the public
rendition is let's talk about democracy
privately they all agree on chaos chaos
works for these guys you know I chaos
actually is a plus in their eyes chaos
and the Middle East works and that's
what that's why they're not unhappy with
this so we're really in trouble what I
would what I would say on that is you
know can the United States have a
positive role something something good a
presence that is positive not negative
and the answer is of course we can look
we stand for so many good things and the
world knows as bad as this
administration has been as bad as the
clinton administration was the world
still looks to us to be leaders on many
things the key thing about leadership
though and again some i learned this in
the military your best leaders are
people who shout and dictate your best
leaders are those who lead by example
who motivate and when we talk about the
united nations you know the united
states going to the united nations and
being an effective member is not a
capitulation of American sovereignty
it's actually the best chance for
America to display the leadership skills
that the world so sadly needs and so
sadly wants and that's the positive role
that the United States could be playing
today okay well I'd like to thank the
cameras from c-span and democracy now
and people from Nation magazine Victor
Navasky is here with us tonight